why from Los Angeles the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
presents Oscar the 64th annual Academy
Awards
brought to you by
the most unforgettable women in the
world wear red lock chevrolet the cars
and trucks more people depend on the
prudential in a changing world one thing
remains rock-solid
the prudential and coca-cola classic you
can't beat the real thing
it's Twilight in California where movie
fans have been kept on since early
morning outside the Darby Chandler
Pavilion you're invited to share the
film communities at night as the stars
arrive
celebrating her first nomination for
Kate
an actor now a director as well Omaha's
Menominee Edward James Olmos
she has a perfect of graded Oscars to
nominations to in Sally beetle
he made a big splash in the films big
and splash Tom Hanks
together the Oscar night Whoopi Goldberg
in Tel Aviv Alvin
star of the new hit movie pop Oh King
Santonio buck Pettis three nominations
two actors actor producer director Kevin
Costner
young beautiful intelligent a winning
combination in any league do henna
the meaning of Medicine Silence of the
Lambs Oscar nominee for Best Actor
Anthony Hopkins - Oscar nominations for
boys in the hood John Singer Hill
Oscar nominee profess actress the
irrepressible fit Midler a first-time
nominee and a crowd favorite Nick Nolte
choreographer director Debbie Allen and
husband nor Nixon
last year's winner for Supporting Actor
Joe Pesci
last year's Oscar winner for best
actress Kathy Bates
the controversial director producer and
screenwriter Oscar nominee Oliver Stone
Oscar winner for the work in fruit sees
on earth Angelica Houston
first time nominee for Best Actress
Laura Dern
everybody's definition of glass Academy
award-winner audrey hepburn
from the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse to tabulate the balloting and
guarantee the secrecy and the integrity
of the results mr. Frank Johnson and mr.
Dan Lyle winner of the Oscar for his
performance in glory Denzel Washington
star of coasts dirty dancing into
presenter of tonight's show Patrick
Swayze one of Hollywood's bright new
stars and a presenter tonight Rebecca De
Mornay celebrating over 40 years in
films kept tonight with another Oscar
nomination Jack Palance screenwriter
novelist Fannie Flagg newlyweds and new
parents Warren Beatty and Annette Bening
ladies and gentlemen the oscar-winning
actor who is serving his third term as
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences
mr. Karl Malden
hello again it's been a year since I
welcome to our last Academy Awards and
what a year it was the maps of the world
have changed governments changed
political climates economics and
fashions continue to change but at least
one thing remains constant the pure joy
of movies and for me it's a joy to watch
them it's a joy to help make them and
it's a joy to serve this Academy that
encourages excellence by celebrating the
best of what we do now this has been an
in year for movies intelligent intuitive
inspired individual a year nourished by
stunning performances and imaginative
screenplays and so tonight we expect
more golden moments with Oscar and not
only has it been a golden year on the
screen but also in the Academy where we
have opened a spanking new center for
motion pictures study and if you haven't
seen it I want you all the go I invite
you all but first we have some joyful
business to take care of here
you